we are continuing to follow that
breaking news tonight good evening to
you thank you for joining us on eight
news now at five i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez we now have an update
to a murder in north las vegas
neighborhood which is right off of
camino el dorado parkway and clayton
that's not too far from sea strand park
madison kimbrough is there live where
police have been on the scene since
before and lunchtime today madison
i just got an update from police a
64-year-old woman was shot and killed a
31-year-old man arrested take a look
behind me as you can see the crime tape
is still up here on giant oak street and
little bow avenue i'm told this happened
about 11 15 this morning the man
arrested is the son of the woman when
police arrived to the neighborhood a
witness pointed him out and he was taken
into custody no word why the man shot
his mom it's still unclear if they lived
together a forensic unit is currently
investigating between two houses there
has been a white vehicle parked in the
middle of the street that appears to
have been searched through by police
neighbors who live on giant oak have
been unable to enter the area until the
investigation wraps up so we will keep
you updated as we will be out here all
afternoon giving you the latest details
reporting live in north las vegas
madison kimbrough live local now